every day emanuelle lisara fetches
firewood from the olive grove where he
and six thousand refugees live on the
island of samos the camp was built to
cope with six hundred and eighty most
live in makeshift Hut's with no
electricity or heat and rely on their
wood fires for warmth any way to Mars
coming
eat before do you can eat mutton is good
here we don't feel comfortable here
everything is bad here we live like any
male asylum seekers mainly from
Afghanistan Syria and Ghana construct
their own homes with timber and
waterproof sheets
handed out by charities sanitary
facilities a few and the olive grove is
littered with human waste all these
problems are supposedly going to be
solved in a new camp being built around
a disused slaughterhouse in the
mountains but it's designed for 1,500
people
nowhere near the numbers currently on
the island that's because the
three-month old conservative
government's new policy is never to have
such overcrowding in future Moria camp
on the island of Lesbos is also at
record numbers thirteen and a half
thousand people are packed in and around
the camp more than four times as many as
it was designed to house the manager of
the camp for the past three years agrees
with the government about what the
problem is the answer in a ward is
constant overpopulation we never managed
to remain at 3,000 as a state entity we
can never turn people away and tell them
where fault someone has to receive them
and register them and cater to their
needs overcrowding creates tension a
recent fire killed a female refugee
causing a riot among outraged others the
government is now shipping hundreds of
asylum seekers to the mainland but it
wants to stem the flow of new arrivals
as well
it wants enforcement of the eu-turkey
statement of 2016 whereby turkey agreed
to readmit migrants who don't qualify
for asylum but it has taken under one
percent of the asylum seekers who've
crossed from its shores the government
plans to intensify the use of the
eu-turkey statement to return 10,000
people to Turkey next year
that's a 20-fold increase on the rate of
returns so far and it wants European
Union members to share the asylum burden
by relocating many of the 70,000 Asylum
applicants now in Greece 60% of refugees
crossing the Mediterranean to Europe
this year have arrived via Greece EU
officials say solving the problem here
is now the priority jumps are applause
al-jazeera in the easter Jian